it feels like it's been ages since the
second season of West world ended in a
dazzling spectacle of sacrifice splendor
and of course gunshots in a way the long
wait for season three feels appropriate
for a show that has always played fast
and loose of its viewers perception of
the passage of time
now that season three is almost here
fans of HBO's mind-bending sci-fi
Western our hope to soon find answers to
many of the questions raised in the
shocking season two finale the passenger
what can we expect when we return to the
show's mesmerizing robot filled universe
what Shawn as we round up all the
information we could find about what
lies in store for us in season three of
West's world after a seemingly
interminable 21 month hiatus West well
third season will finally premiere on
HBO on March 15 2020 the series analysis
returndate fear a perplexing tweet in
January of 2020 which was accompanied by
a video outlining the timeline of the
divergence the divergence begins in 2019
with some events that have already
happened in the real world hinting now
West Welles third season may wind up
hitting uncomfortably close to home the
video then goes on to catalog points in
the divergence that haven't happened yet
ending with the most recent divergence
in 2058 as a voice-over worries that
there may be someone they haven't
accounted for while it's easy to assume
that the 2058 incident refers to the
host uprising at the end of season two
that event actually takes place in 2050
- according to security footage of
Maeve's escape at the end of season 1
this raises a question of just what
occurs six years later and to whom
exactly the video is referring while a
number of familiar faces are returning
for season 3 the end of season 2 marked
the definitive farewell for several
others Anthony Hopkins Park creator
Robert Ford has been dead since the end
of season 1 and although he continued to
appear regularly in flashbacks and
visions co-creator Lisa joy confirmed
that he's now gone for good
meanwhile Jimmy Simpsons character
William will still be very much alive in
season 3 but will be portrayed
exclusively by Ed Harris as Simpson
revealed at TCA that he hasn't been
asked to return as for Shannon
Woodward's determined true seeker L see
she was tragically murdered at the end
of season 2 and sure
Oh Jonathan Nolan has confirmed that for
now at least LC is truly gone less clear
is the fate of james marsden stalwarts
cowboy teddy teddy committed suicide
near the end of season two determined to
die rather than become a monster but to
Laura's left his brain pearl in the
forge leaving his consciousness free to
cross over into the sublime nothing has
yet been said one way or another about
Marsten's return but since this is
West's world we know better than to rule
anything else as for the host whose
consciousness crossed into the grassy
plains other sublime mother mechanical
bodies plummeted off a cliff showrunner
lisa joy confirmed they're gone for good
including ghost nation leader acha
chatter his lost love Kahana and Maeve's
daughter speaking to The Hollywood
Reporter Joyce said the stakes and the
family of it are important it's not
something where I think the humans can
type it up and get back in and start
messing with them anymore
it's what so many hosts sacrificed so
much for to see their kind to this safe
space at the end of season two the real
Charlotte Ale is dead and gone murdered
by her host doppelganger which was
imbued with a consciousness of Dolores
however this new host version of
Charlotte successfully makes it out of
the park as does Bernard and is
ultimately able to construct a new
Dolores host body to inhabit however
when asked by Entertainment Weekly where
the season 3 will follow double Dolores
Jonathan Nolan responded not really the
question of who's who and what we're
looking at is something we're excited to
play with we're excited to withhold a
little from the audience but it's
complicated it's an intriguing answer
and one Tessa Thompson is eager to
explore in season 3 in an interview with
The Hollywood Reporter Thompson said of
her new identity it's a total
GameChanger
I want to put on a lot of different
characters that to me is a real exciting
potential in all of this Thompson has
also said that while in the past her
character has seemed unsympathetic to
the hosts experiences and the fact that
they're not in control of their own
lives we may see a different side to her
in season 3 but I think what we come to
learn in the third season is the world
that Hale comes from is maybe not so
dissimilar and that's something that I
have found really fascinating about this
season Thompson's house wasn't the only
one to make it out to the park in the
season 2 finale though before she left
she took five pole shaped control units
each housing the consciousness of one
host just which hosts AR remains to be
seen and according to Jonathan Nolan
even the writers had fully decided who
was in Dolores purse at the end of
season two however when the inhabitants
of those pearls are eventually revealed
in season 3 Nolan said the goal of the
right scissors for their choices to
surprise and hopefully delight their
audience while we can rule out any of
the characters that we saw Crossin to
the sublime that still leaves a large
number of hoes to pick from so place
your bets wisely since the early days of
West world fans have suspected that
Ashley Stubbs the parks chief of
security may be a host a theory that
only continued to gain traction
once other characters previously
presumed to be human were revealed to be
hosts this theory was seemingly
confirmed in the passenger during an
intriguing exchange between Stubbs and
the host that looks like Charlotte Hale
birth is being driven by Dolores during
their brief conversation Serbs obviously
realizes the hail isn't all that she
seems but instead of turning her in he
tells her that he was hired so long ago
he can barely remember it saying that
Ford was always very clear about his
role at the park and who he was supposed
to be loyal to call it my core Drive
that's amusing for a bit so ever how the
lines of since blood making it hard for
him to know where his loyalties should
lie Stubbs tells her that she's free to
go after making it very clear that he
knows who and what she is I'm
responsible for every host
inside-the-park we expect to see more of
how Stubbs fits into Ford's plan when he
returns in Westworld season three more
the first two seasons of West world have
been mostly told from the point of view
of Dolores and William otherwise known
as the man in black season three seems
to be taking a sharp left turn
the first intriguing glimpse at West
Wells new season followed a brand new
character named Caleb played by Aaron
Paul through a series of events in what
appears to be the real world outside of
Dallas Park Paul cryptically told The
Wrap that his character will bring
excitement danger suspense and honesty
to the series but other than that he's
playing his cards very close to the vest
when it comes to Caleb revealing only
that he is a construction worker with a
good friend George his robot he's a red
robot according to Jonathan Nolan Caleb
will challenge two lorises notions about
the nature of humanity although whether
her interactions with Caleb or Suffern
their feelings to what humans or just
further convinced that her ruthless
attitude is justified is yet to be
determined all Paul can tell us says he
crossed paths with this lovely lovely
being very soon and they create a
relationship in addition to Breaking Bad
star Aaron Paul other new additions to
the season three cast include master of
nones Lena weaith former NFL running
back Marshawn Lynch and rapper Kid Cudi
credited on the show with Scotts muscari
no details have been revealed about any
of their characters but judging by the
trailer it appears as though wait and
Lynch will be playing Paul's accomplices
in various illegal activities while
cadiz character will be spending at
least some of his time in prison
additionally if vincent cassell will be
coming aboard a season 3's new villain
who can be seen in the final trailer for
West world's third season making maven
intriguing offer Dolores I want you to
track her down and kill her more viewers
of West's world are no strangers
artificial life-forms season 3 will
introduce us to a different type of
robot than the human presenting hosts
were used to George is a standard
construction robots Dallas model G 267
built to serve as a helpful co-worker
for Caleb George doesn't speak and
likely won't have much in common with
his mechanical counterparts from inside
the park speaking about Dolores on the
other hose who escaped the park into the
real world
the end of the second season Jonathan
Nolan said part of what our hosts find
is that they're caught in between their
fashion to look like human beings and
act like them but they have more in
common with the mechanical pieces in our
world robots like George and the other
real world worker buds will play an
important role in the upcoming season
contrasting the human-like traits of the
hosts with their mechanical origins
according to Noland these more
utilitarian robots have been designed
for a specific purpose and the hosts
have been designed to be emotional
mirrors for us although a few main
characters managed to escape at the end
of season two there are still others
left on the inside with several areas of
force bizarre theme parks as yet
unexplored in addition to Westworld
season two introduced viewers to Shogun
world and the rush but the show's
official Dallas destinations website
teases three additional parks we may
very well travel to one or more of these
remaining parks in season three know
than enjoy of privacy hinted that the
show may eventually visit the Roman and
medieval worlds from Michael Crichton's
original 1973 movie as for the sixth
world it may have already been revealed
in the season 3 trailer which shows me
even a place that looks a lot like Nazi
occupied Europe during World War two
this also seems to match the glitchy
image of the third park on the Telos
website which seems to shape planes
flying over a light brick town with
smoke rising from it while at first
glance world war ii doesn't exactly seem
like a prime vacation spot if there's
one thing we've learned about the elite
clientele of Delos theme parks is that
they're drawn to violent settings where
enemies lurk around every corner
but since the world war ii park is
possibly an even worse place for a woman
of color to exists in a Wild West Park
we can only hope that Maeve isn't stuck
there for long in the final moments of
the west-world season two finale we
follow ed harris as william as he
stumbles out of an elevator badly
injured and meets his daughter Emily in
the rubble of what he assumes must be
part of the park since he actually
killed Emily earlier in the season Polly
Emma seems as consciousness has been
uploaded to the forge but she assures
him that what he's experiencing is real
I'm already doing a thing harder no
systems Lanka a conversation that
follows echoes of ones that we saw
earlier in the season between the
younger William and James Delos in which
William repeatedly tested the host body
that housed a lose his consciousness
waiting for it to break down William
discern so he's now a host and when he
asks how many times he's been tested
Emily responds itís been a long time
speaking to the rap about William and
Emily's scene Alisa Joyce said he's in a
very different timeline the whole place
looks destroyed and then she explains
that all of that stuff happened long ago
but that was real but now something has
happened and the man is now the subject
awesome iteration of the man is now the
subject of testing the roles have been
completely reversed the final trailer
for Westworld season 3 looks very
different than anything we've seen from
the show before while we do seem to get
a couple glimpses of parks most of it
appears to be set in the real world
where the Loras and Caleb would join
forces with the host modeled after
Charlotte ale although she worries that
they are severely outnumbered here were
those five there are lots of
possibilities including Bernard Stubbs
and resurrected teddy or possibly new
characters the trailer also teases a
surprising team up between Dolores and
William World opposing them is none
other than Maeve who is very much alive
despite meeting a bloody end at the end
of season two the action-packed trailer
bills to a climactic shot of maven
Dolores both clad all in black
confronting each other on a city
overpass we may not know a lot about
what to expect from season three but we
have no doubt that the next showdown
between Dolores and Maeve is going to be
one for the ages check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos but your favorite stuff
are coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and to the bail so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]